Donald Trump's son-in-law and advisor
Jared Kushner
is now not the only Trump associate to
get pulled into the Russia scandal in
the last week we already knew that
Donald Trump's personal lawyer Michael
Cohen was part of the FBI's
investigation into ties between Donald
Trump's campaign and Russia we've talked
about Michael Cohen acting as a sort of
middleman between Ukraine Russia and
Trump in regards to the plan to lift
sanctions on Russia people involved were
caught lying about the timeline of
events that went on with that and recall
that Michael Cohen hand-delivered this
plan involving the lifting of Russian
sanctions to disgraced former national
security adviser Michael Flynn and lied
about it and we have now found out that
Michael Cohen Donald Trump's personal
lawyer has now been pulled in to the
congressional Trump Russia investigation
House and Senate Intelligence Committee
investigations have asked for the
cooperation of trumps personal attorney
Michael Cullen in their probes
requesting testimony requesting certain
records that might shed light onto
Michael Collins connections to Russia
and Cohen has refused not exactly the
response you'd expect from someone with
nothing to hide who is completely
innocent this could actually lead to the
subpoena of Michael Cohen's documents as
well as his testimony in these
investigations the Senate Select
Intelligence Committee has already voted
unanimously to allow their leadership to
subpoena those documents remember and
this is where it's all starting to come
together remember that when the Trump
Russia blackmail dossier as it's sort of
known went public a couple of months ago
the dossier asserted that trumps
personal attorney Michael Cohen met with
Russian officials in Prague in 2016 and
was sort of the primary mediator for
Donald Trump in those Trump Russia
communications ABC new on ABC News
Trump's attorney Michael Cohen gave a
very carefully worded response about
that where he said quote I've never
actually walked the land in Prague
and last August I was not in Prague keep
in mind that Michael Cohen is a lawyer I
wonder if in the mind of a lawyer
landing at an airport in Prague but I
don't know never clearing customs would
legally not be walking the land in
Prague because he didn't actually enter
the country you're not legally in the
country until you've cleared customs did
he maybe land at an airport outside of
Prague used for private air travel and
never actually went to Prague itself or
whatever meetings he allegedly had we
just don't know but that is a very oddly
worded denial from Michael Cohen anyway
last week Cohen visited the White House
to consult with Trump about hiring a
team of personal lawyers to represent
him in the Trump Russia stuff we know
that Donald Trump did that I reported to
you about that last week this is the guy
Michael Cohen who has helped Trump deal
with everything from frivolous libel
lawsuits to rape allegations and if
there is anyone who's going to be
calculated and slippery in all of this
its Trump's lawyer who probably is among
those with the most intimate knowledge
of trumps legal life and how to best
deal with these situations related to
the investigations he's sort of the if
you watch Breaking Bad or better call
Saul Michael Cohen is sort of like the
Saul Goodman of Trump's organization and
if you've ever seen interviews with
Michael Cohen you know how slick he can
be big picture trend all of the
investigations are growing in scope not
shrinking in scope not petering out and
there's a discussion probably at this
point a couple discussions about this on
our reddit discussion forum which I
encourage you to participate in david
pakman.com slash read it that's our EDD
IT today's program is made possible in
part by Gamefly which is sort of like
netflix for video games they've got over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can also stream
games you don't even need a gaming
console or a computer because you can
stream
James through your Amazon fire stick or
Roku box and then use your mobile phone
as the controller you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price never with due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a 30 day free
trial at Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included no
contracts and you can also stream the
games I think I mentioned that you can
also rent games through the mobile app
get a free 30 day trial for david pakman
show viewers and listeners and support
our show at Gamefly offer.com forward
slash TDP s